el régimen de Sadam hussein cayó hace 20
años pero la situación de la mujer en la
sociedad iraquí Sigue estando lejos de
lo que muchas esperaban en 2003 cuando
se estaba formando el nuevo sistema de
gobernanza del país los derechos y
libertades que queremos queremos hablar
caminar por la calle sin que nos miren
mal y que no nos subestimen
Aunque exijamos cosas quién nos va a
escuchar nadie exigimos cosas pero no
conseguimos nada
ahora está mejor que antes pero espero
que las mujeres selectas cumplan su
papel trabajando para mejorar los
servicios y las infraestructuras para
todos los ciudadanos la cuestión de la
representación femenina en la política
Fue una gran lucha en los años que
siguieron a la invasión de Irak liderada
por Estados Unidos bajo el régimen de
Sadam hussein las mujeres no tenían
sitio en el parlamento
Lleva más de 50 años luchando por los
Derechos Humanos recuerda un momento
crucial cuando hubo que redactar la
nueva constitución desde el principio
insistimos en una cuestión importante la
cuota de mujeres exigimos que no menos
del 40% de las mujeres estuvieran
representadas en el parlamento y los
consejos provinciales fue solo una
victoria parcial cuando la Constitución
fue finalmente ratificada en 2005
estipulaba que solo el 25% de los
escaños debían reservarse a las mujeres
pero gracias a ello nurel Julia hawhi
pudo entrar en el parlamento 16 años
después
esos partidos estaban dando cargos a las
mujeres solo para cubrir la cuota que
ordena la ley tenemos que empoderar a
las mujeres estos partidos estaban
incorporando a mujeres débiles sin
experiencia política a propósito
en realidad los derechos de la mujer en
Irak han avanzado poco en 20 años la
sociedad iraquí sigue siendo ampliamente
patriarcal y a menudo se aplican los
códigos tribales la principal lucha de
las activistas de Derechos Humanos hoy
en día es proteger mejor a las mujeres
contra la violencia y siguen pidiendo
nuevas